μίζολή σύννομα στην σίαν αυτό το πρόβλημαή το ρικέστρ πάντων σήκωσαν τχαράκι το τα πέτον
και έκαναν έτι αρά δεδεν δεν άκουσαν ένα ολημπιωνίκι τι θελε να τους πει συνουσίαν
δεν ακολούθηκα δεν αακολουθήσαν τις θυμοκρατικές διαδικασίες βάση του καταστατικού της ομοσποντίας αλλά είναι η
θεώρησαν όις ακολούθησαν γιατί των ακούς πάύλωμ έναν ολημπιωνικί να λέει ότι έκαναν το χαλή
πάνω έβαλαν γιατί στην κύπρο ίμαστε είναι συνηθισμένο μένομένω αυτό λλά όταν κάνει παράπον και
δεν δεν θέλω να διαχωρίσω από τους άλλους αθλήτες αλλά ει σε ένας ολυμπιωνίκης δύο
φορες όταν οι αρμόδιι δεν άκουν και κάνουν το χαλή και τα βάζον τα προβλήματα
από κάτω σίγουρα προβληματισμόύ μόνο προκαλή και σε σέναμπουέχείς προσφεριτώς σίγορα ππρολιδμαρισμόμων προκαλίκαι σ έμεραν
και σε όλο των κόσμον αλλά απ τη στυμή που εγώ έκανα τηενεργεια μου μετά
είδα ότι δεν ακολουθηκαακολουθήσαν αυτά πονακολουθήσουν και σηνα την επιστοαλλά μετά δεν είμαι εγώ πλέον
αρμόδιος που θα συνεχίσω αστωπούμε ν κρίνο ούτε δικαστικά αλλιώς αλλά υπάρχουν εναι αρμόδιηφορίς που
θα μπορούσαν να πούν να λεπτού τι γίνεται εδώ εγώ δεν το οποίρα παρακάτω γιατί
στην ουσίάν πλέον αρχίζει σκεφθύρεσ και μπαίνεις στον θα κόνηση ζαγωγικά πάντα κονταστο δικαιών και
είναι κάτι που στη οσίά θα σου κάνει πολύ παρισωτεριζημια σαν πάύλος σε σχέση με
το καλο που προσπαθείς να κάνεις και σύπροσπαθείς να κάνεις βλέπεις ότι δεν έχει αντααπόκριση
πάντοτε με δίκαιον τρόπον και αυτό δεν το επαικτινα το θέμα θα προσπαθήσεις ώστοσο γιατί
δαμε και τον πρώτον της δημοκρατίας να η κοντά στους αθλητές ήρθε στο παρις μετά
σα σδε και